- So I'm like, "Coach, I'm not missing the Met Gala for a BROWNS game.”
[Group laughs]
- Oh, what’s up, boys? We talking about
[Mispronouncing] Why-ves Saint Laurent?
[Group laughs]
- Sorry, the Receiver Club is for smart and classy positions.
- Yeah, I don’t think the Seahawks even have a tight end.
- I’ll show them smart and classy.
Yo, guys!
[Group gasps]
- SOME FACES NEED BEARDS.
- We have to prove we're not just dumb linemen with hands.
- [Together:] HEAR, HEAR!
- It’s time to start…
TIGHT END UNIVERSITY.
- WHERE’D TRAVIS GO?
- ALL RIGHT, RECRUITS, SING IT WITH ME.
- [Together:] ♪♪♪ AT T.E.U, WE HONOR THEE  PASS-BLOCKING TRUE BELIEVERS ♪♪♪
- So how long do we have to be stuck together?
- ♪♪♪ WE’RE LIKE LINEMEN, BUT HERE’S THE CATCH: WE’RE ELIGIBLE RECEIVERS ♪♪♪
- I heard there was a party.
- [Together:] Super senior Jimmy Graham!
- ♪♪♪ CATCH, BLOCK, CATCH, BLOCK, DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE CALL IS? ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ IT DOESN’T MATTER, JUST ACT LIKE TONY GONZALEZ! ♪♪♪
- I haven’t been this emotional since WrestleMania XIX.
- FUNDRAISER SO WE CAN BUY MORE BACKWARDS HATS!
- Sup...we’re here to save your party.
- Uh, Noah Fant? No-Ah can't let you in.
[Group gasps]
- There’s nothing we can do. Technically, it's an accredited university.
- Nick's description of Gatsby is just so inconsistent.
- PERHAPS NICK CARRAWAY...IS UNRELIABLE NARRATOR?
- [Together:] OHHHH.
- You vs. Us. The Annual Touchdown Dance.
You win the crown, and we’ll go the way of the fullback and just disappear.
- Come with us, kid.
- Oh, I’m a tight end.
- [Together:] WHAT?!?!
- Dang. One day.
- WELCOME TO THE TOUCHDOWN DANCE!
- Ooof, is this what Cam is doin' these days?
- SHOW. US. THAT. SWAG.
♪♪♪
Yo, this dude's intense as hell.
Oh, it’s like a two-person scene. Cute.
- All right. Come on, Killer Trav. It’s all up to you.
- It’s not goosey. It’s GUCCI.
- Tyreek is Cheetah, and Travis is THE WARTHOG!
- It’s your brother, Jason. F--k you. Catching is for pretty boys.
- All right, the call of the tight end:
WOOOOO!
- [Together:] WOOOOOO!!!
- I’d like to announce that I’m officially stepping down as head coach of the Jacksonville Jaguars.
I’ll be going back to college to become the coach of Tight End University.
- It’s not a power 5 school!
- What?
I’d like to announce my total and complete commitment to the Jacksonville Jaguars.
Go…[sigh]...Duval.